I want to say something very briefly
here at the top before we get going
Andrew Clavin here at the Daily wire has
been growing a beard recently and as I'm
sure you've noticed if you watch his
show which I hope you do and I've heard
through the grapevine and that is
through Twitter that there has been a
campaign among some people within the
company to try to convince him pressure
him to shave his beard now I'm not going
to name any names ben shapiro
ben shapiro in case you missed that let
me just say this I stand with Clavin and
his beard as a fellow beardsman I have
myself experienced beard related
harassment and abuse you could not
possibly understand the persecution that
our community faces because of our faces
unless you've been there because of my
beard I have been I have been told that
I look like a hobo a Yeti an unemployed
lumberjack a desert island Castaway I've
been called unkempt and disheveled and
this is just my wife talking okay you
can only imagine what everyone else says
so I stand in solidarity with my fellow
bearded deli wire host and I stand
firmly against follicle discrimination
and in an act of protest I will be
growing my beard even longer I will grow
it until it is down to my knees or until
such a time as when my wife's complaints
are growing too loud whichever comes
first
all right I just want to say that to
begin with because this is a very
important issue to me all right here's a
here's a story that the story I really
want to start with today I think it
perfectly encapsulates the fatal flaws
in the left's identity politics and
that's why I want to talk about it I
mean this was a this was there was a
report on this in The Daily wire
yesterday you can go see a UCLA
professor named Corinne bender Eskie
wrote an article in the Harvard Business
Review titled making us fire departments
more diverse and inclusive oh yes you
know this is going to be good and
it exceeds expectations alright so
here's here's how the article begins it
says picture a typical firefighter who
comes to mind if you imagined a white
man that's understandable ninety-six
percent of us career firefighters are
men and 82 percent are white this is
striking especially when you compare it
to the US military which is 85% men and
60% white and local police forces which
are 88% men and 73% way many fire
departments recognize that their lack of
diversity is a problem and say that
they're committed to increasing racial
and gender diversity and then she goes
on a bit later she says to succeed as a
firefighter stereotypically masculine
traits like brawn and courage are simply
not enough I agree you also have to know
how to put out fires
she says though that firefighters also
need the intellectual social and
emotional skills required to deliver
medical emergency aid support each other
through traumatic experiences and engage
intimately with the communities that
they serve engaging intimately that is a
that is a key skill set for for
firefighters
intimate engagement whatever that means
she says and yet in my research on
reducing gender bias and my work
conducting training on general diversity
and inclusion within fire departments I
can only imagine what you love to sit in
on one of her one of her training
sessions she says I find that when
evaluating fit and competence
firefighters tend to default to a
reductive set of traits physical
strength evaluated through strict
physical fitness for example evaluated
through strict fitness tests that is and
these only serve to maintain white men's
dominance in the fire services she goes
on then to complain more about the lack
of women in the fire service and then
she complains that there aren't enough
black people as well then of course you
guessed it
she's also mad that there aren't enough
gay firefighters she writes the fire
services challenges with diversity go
beyond gender and race openly gay men
are exceedingly rare in the fire service
the men who the few who are out of the
closet face severe social exclusion and
then she quotes a gay firefighter
talking about his challenges so and then
she goes on to talk about the things
that fire departments are doing to to
diversify and attract more women and do
what she wants but she says that those
efforts are not good enough they never
are obviously so she suggests that the
whole idea of of being a firefighter it
needs to be changed the whole paradigm
needs to be shifted the Liberals are
always looking to shift paradigms and so
they need to shift this paradigm to she
says that we've we find that reframing
the professional prototype of what it
means to be a firefighter to emphasize
the importance of legitimate
stereotypically feminine traits like
compassion has promising effects on
creating a more inclusive environment
for women we had active duty
firefighters and members of the general
public watching videos of a white male
fire captain describing the most
important traits of a successful modern
firefighter when he listed compassion
first followed by team orientation and
physical strength so the ability to
fight fires isn't even on this list at
all
she says viewers perceptions of female
firefighters abilities and support for
gender diversification policy were much
more positive than they were when they
watched and present those same traits in
reverse order yes because when you're
fighting a fire or responding to a
medical emergency the most important
thing is that you feel compassionate not
that you have the skill strength stamina
courage knowledge technical proficiency
not any of that no you have to feel
compassionate right and and obviously if
you're ever trapped in a burning
building and let's say there are two
people's firefighters outside one of
them is going to rush into the building
to save you right and let's say one of
the firefighters is especially strong
and especially good at rescuing people
from buildings and the other firefighter
isn't as good but he's very
compassionate which one would you want
rushing into the building
your life is on the line obviously the
compassionate one right because if you
both burn to death at least you know he
can give you a hug while you're dying
admits the flames I guess now we could
ask the question why is it actually a
problem that there aren't more female
and gay firefighters and this is almost
a scandalous question these days because
it's just assumed that it must be a
problem when a certain profession or
sector of society is dominated by one
gender or one race or whatever well it's
only a problem if it's dominated by men
and especially by white men if there's a
there are plenty of professions that are
dominated by women nobody have you
noticed that nobody is saying hey what
can we do to make sure that we get more
men involved in hairdressing or we get
more men involved in social work what
can we do about that
have you noticed we're never looking to
diversify those professions the
professions and there are plenty of
professions like this where women are
the dominant force no we don't want
diversity there we're fine without
diversity there no we only want
diversity in areas where men are the
predominant demographic represented and
but why why does it matter our straight
white male firefighters less effective
than female firefighters are they less
effective than transgender firefighters
or gay firefighters if they aren't less
effective and if indeed perhaps when it
comes to men versus women they're more
effective then who cares who cares about
the lack of diversity it seems that the
people who complain about a lack of
diversity they they still have not
figured out why a lack of diversity
matters have you noticed that that all
the complaints about diversity nobody
can explain what exactly is the actual
tangible practical benefit of having
diversity no one can ever explain that
so they say well there's a lack of
diversity okay so well it's bad because
a lack of diversity means there won't be
diversity this is obviously the problem
with treating diversity as if it's as if
diversity itself is this objectively
desirable thing in every context it's a
very modern it's a very Western concept
that says that anything and everything
can be improved with diversity yet
nobody again can actually explain how
that works and they won't even try you
know they just insist on it well in the
case of firefighters diversity is at
best irrelevant you're not gonna find
any study proving that more diverse fire
houses are somehow more effective in
performing their actual jobs because
that's obviously not the case you aren't
going to to make a fire house more
effective by replacing some of the men
with women I think if anything very
likely it will go in the opposite
direction now here's another thing to
consider this article just dismisses the
idea that firefighters need to be
physically strong and tough which is
absurd obviously the author lists other
qualities like compassion and the
ability to engage intimately with the
community still haven't figured out what
that means but you notice what she
didn't list if we're gonna list things
besides just physical strength and I
certainly agree that firefighters need
to have other things besides physical
strength although physical strength is
clearly extremely important but there
are other things too that she didn't
list that are not necessarily related to
physical strength how about fraternity
camaraderie unity now I've never been a
firefighter but I imagine that these
things are important in a firehouse and
when it comes to fraternity and unity
and and camaraderie then in those
contexts commonality not necessarily
diversity is what facilitates that if
you've got people working full-time at a
firehouse and they've got this stressful
job and they're doing dangerous things
you want them to be unified you want
them to care about each other too
be on the same page to get along I think
you would want all of that and it's
going to be easier to facilitate that
and to engender that when you have
commonality so even when you look at
some of the intangible things sometimes
a if you want to put it this way a lack
of diversity can can be beneficial even
in those areas because the fact is
people relate and get along with you
know men relate differently to men they
get along differently with men then then
they do with women that's just the fact
but oddly enough she doesn't mention
that all right moving on moving on to
this the actor Idris Elba stringer bell
for for those who have good taste in TV
shows was trending on Twitter the other
day and usually when a male celebrity
trends randomly on social media you know
what's coming next but there was a
curveball this time because he was
trending sort of for the opposite reason
he was trending because people were
complimenting him women and feminists
especially were complimenting him now
it's not unusual for women to compliment
Idris Elba but in this case everybody
was very delighted with comments that he
made about the the me2 movement in an
interview he was asked he was asked if
it's difficult to be a man these days in
the era of me too and he responded very
succinctly he said well it's only
difficult if you're a man with something
to hide that was his response people
were very impressed with this I am not
so much impressed with it because this
is precisely the logic that has
justified every witch hunt ever in
history the whole the whole thing that
makes the me to crusade difficult for
men is the air of suspicion the
accusatory light that it casts on all
men so let me ask Idris Elba this
if a man is falsely accused would you
say that it shouldn't be difficult for
him because the accusation is false and
thus he has nothing to hide no it's
difficult precisely for that reason now
I know that of course elbow was was was
not really trying to necessarily
communicate a fully coherent thought
here he was he was actually just trying
to keep the the pitchfork mob from
showing up at his doorstep by placating
it with stuff like this but that's not
gonna work unfortunately and that's the
other mistake that people make when it
comes to witch hunts and pitchfork mobs
they think that they can avoid being
targeted by going along with it and by
encouraging them but see that's that's
it doesn't work that way we've seen how
this ends and it never ends well that's
for certain one other thing just in
general just in general about this if
you don't have anything to hide cliche
because that logic is never never good
it has never been employed to advance
any good cause ever anytime someone is
saying anytime someone is using this
argument saying well if you don't have
anything to hide you know that whatever
they're trying to justify by using that
argument is terrible you automatically
know it
for reasons that I've that I've
explained it but also also because
everybody has something to hide as in
everybody has things that they don't
want to be made public but that doesn't
make those things evil or illegal okay
just because a person has certain things
that they don't want out there in public
view things that they want to keep
private that doesn't mean that they're
guilty of anything at all it's like if a
stranger walked up to you and said or if
a cop if a cop walked up to you and said
I'm gonna need to look through your
phone and you say no and then they say
well what do you have something to hide
you're doing something illegal well I'm
not doing anything illegal but yeah I
have something to hide from you I want
to hide the contents of my phone from
you not because there's anything bad or
illegal in there but just because it's
none of your business that's why I I
just want to keep it private because
there are things that I want to keep
private because I have a private life
the fact that I don't want to open it up
for public consumption
doesn't mean that I've done something
wrong so that hold that logic that that
whole idea is is incredibly dangerously
flawed all right one other thing and
this starts with a with a funny story
about my son so yesterday my you know I
was at home and my son calls up from the
basement and he says he says I just hit
Jeremiah I'm going into a corner let me
know when I can come out so my son he
smacked his brother and then he put
himself in timeout for doing it which
you really have to respect because the
kid I guess he kind of he looked at the
pros and cons he weighed the wist the
risks and rewards and he decided that
the reward of pummeling his brother was
worth kind of the consequences and then
he faced those consequences like a man
he owned up to it so that's so so that
makes me very proud
and I mentioned this on Twitter just as
a funny parenting anecdote the fact that
my son hit his brother and then put
himself in timeout for it I meant
on Twitter people responded by laughing
about it and so on but there was one
response that was just absolutely
incredible
a woman responded to my tweet with a 10
tweet thread lecturing me on my
parenting and I want to read this to you
because it's just marvelous okay now
here was my original tweet this is what
I said my son just hit his little
brother and then put himself in timeout
that was the that was a whole tweet
that's all I said and then this from
Heather and here's her whole thread in
response to what I said this might be a
little bit out of order but this is what
she said she said to me that speaks to
some possible problems with your
parenting style children often imitate
what they see adults do with everything
but here I am talking about hitting in
other words he hears you say that
hitting is wrong but perhaps he's been
spanked when he's made a mistake so then
he's confused because hitting is wrong
but my dad hits me when I do something
wrong if you have modeled hitting either
through spanking or some form of
domestic violence then your child may be
imitating your actions however he knows
that it is wrong because you've taught
him with your word that hitting is wrong
this is called cognitive dissonance and
it's very distressing to a child use
timeout carefully because she's still
going okay she's still going
use timeout carefully because punishment
comes with all sorts of collateral
challenging behavior and possible
psychological damage it can be very
effective for a cute challenging
behavior like severe self-injury but it
isn't really a good idea to punish minor
challenging behavior like sibling
rivalry also she's still going on
timeout is only effective as punishment
making the behavior happen less in the
future if time in is reinforcing in that
case time out is actually reinforcing
his escape from kid work and you are
shooting yourself in the foot he's
getting what he wants and getting out of
the task in short if I were providing
parent coaching for you professionally
we would have a lot of work to do
that was like 10 or 11 tweets because of
a because of like hey 812 words that I
said about my son so there you go
Heather is and by the way that this was
not a joke she wasn't being satiric I
thought at first
she's kind of being satirical and trying
to be funny but no she's bought 100%
serious
Heather is is not only a parenting
expert but she also has ESP because you
notice I never said anything at all
about spanking I never said one way or
another about that but she looked into
her crystal ball and she diagnosed my
whole existence as a parent which is
very very impressive incredible
incredible stuff now I share this with
you because first of all it's hilarious
but second it is an extreme example of a
very common phenomenon it's a phenomenon
known on the internet as the sanctum AMI
and Heather is like the she is like the
Alpha she is the mommy of all sanctum
Ami's and Sancta mommies are are women
who believe themselves to be parenting
experts and also believe that everyone
in the world is hungry for and in need
of their advice so that anytime you
mention your kids or parenting or family
or anything at all even remotely related
to raising children they will parachute
in like Navy SEALs and start offering
Corrections and criticisms and
everything else now women have to deal
with this kind of thing much more often
than men women are much more often the
targets of Sancta mommies like like
Heather and they are judged often much
more harshly for their perceived
parenting lapses than men are but women
are also pretty good at sniffing out the
Sancta mommies so you know every woman
has other women in her circle who are
like this and so she knows not to bring
up certain subjects around that woman
because then she's going to have to
endure a lecture about it but it's
because of these sorts of people and
it's not just you know I say Sancta
mommies sometimes there are Sancta
daddies it's that is not nearly as
common but they do exist and it's
because of them that everything about
parenting has become controversial every
aspect of parenting is now a matter of
dispute and and debate no matter what
you do as a parent Nomad
no matter what no matter what it is
there will be someone out there ready to
tell you that it's wrong it's abusive
its neglectful you're ruining your
child's life forever no matter what it
is it really does not matter parenting
is is hard enough as it is parenting is
a difficult job but now it's it's even
harder because parents feel like they
have to navigate this minefield and if
they take one small step in the wrong
direction they're gonna destroy their
children because that's what people like
Heather have told them and that is why
here's the here's the moral of the story
it's because of people like Heather and
and those who are in her camp though
perhaps have a less severe case of
whatever she has but it's because of
that that's why I have law as a parent I
have long been at the point where I just
don't care at all what anyone else
thinks about my parent thing it makes no
different
makes no difference to me it is the
least relevant thing to me in the world
I couldn't possibly care any less than I
do about what strangers think about my
parenting and I think that if you want
to function as a parent in modern
society you have to get to that point
where you really just do not care at all
what other people think and say because
if you do care then you're going to be
you're gonna start second-guessing
everything you do and as I said
everything is gonna feel like a
minefield and here's the other thing
when when you hear someone in parting
their parenting wisdom and giving
parenting advice keep in mind that that
nobody actually has any idea what
they're doing okay none of us do as
parents none of us have any idea what
we're doing we're just we're just kind
of fumbling along in the dark here where
we're trying this out we're trying that
out we're trying to see what works I
mean we're dealing with a child is a is
a whole is a person to a child is a
whole other human being separate from
yourself they have their own
their own personality there's only so
much you can do to account for that
there's only so much you could do to
control them and there's only so much
you should try to do to control them so
you're just you're you're dealing with
every child is really different in every
parenting situation is different and so
there are some general principles and
ideas and approaches that might work but
on a case-by-case everyday kind of basis
it's just you're really we're all kind
of lost and confused that's the dirty
little secret that nobody will say we're
all just trying to figure it out as we
go along and and certainly if you're if
you're talking to another parent who's
in the thick of it with you then they're
not any more of an expert than you are
now if you talk to a pest to someone
who's you know in their 60s and they've
they went through the whole parenting
thing now that might be someone who who
can have some good advice my mom is it
my and my mom and dad of good parenting
advice that they could offer but but
even people who are older you also have
to keep in mind that they parented kids
20-30 years ago
they don't actually know what it's like
to parent a kid in in today's world and
so there are different challenges now
that we face that they didn't and there
are challenges that they face that we
don't so it's just it's it's different
and we always have to keep that in mind
so you just figure it out as you go
along and you hope that you're not
screwed up to kids too bad and that's
and that's what that's what parenting is
all right that's all all right I'll
leave it there that's my that's that's
my parenting advice is just don't screw
up your kids too much that's that's all
you can hope for him I'll talk to you
get you talk to you guys tomorrow
Godspeed